when you're writing a screenplay do you
start with an outline
i start with somewhat of an outline um i
need to know
where i am and then where i'm going or
where i just came from
so usually for me personally when i'm
starting to write it's not coming from a
from a starting place it's coming from a
scene i already had
so i write that scene out the most vivid
thing about what i think about this idea
i write that scene out without any it
doesn't have to fit anywhere i don't
know where this is but i just see
these characters doing this at some
point so i start there kind of kind of
get my groove going and start to
like yeah i really feel this moment i've
seen this moment i'm very a very visual
writer and a very
when ideas come to me they come to me
almost as like a movie um so i'm able to
write that down
and then now i go to an outline because
i don't i don't even know where this is
so i know i'm here but i don't know
where this is in the story or anything
like that um so i just start
with okay where's it ending where are we
going and then go from there so i kind
of
in a very non-linear way bounce about
the outline and then in the end which to
outline could take two months
i mean in the end i see it and i'm like
okay now this is some type of map
with the understanding that we can
deviate from it
how many scripts would you say you've
written even if you haven't shown them
to anyone
good question i have written from start
to finish on my own five
um in a collaborative effort i i would
have to sit here and count
for a moment for a moment because i've
written on so many things and
helped writers do so many things so um
i'm not really sure how many that is
it's more than ten
um but for start to finish um is five
um on my own and then i have two three
maybe about four unfinished ones three
or four unfinished yeah
what are the pros and cons of writing on
your own and then writing
with either another person or a group of
people yeah um
pros and cons of writing on your own
versus a group i think changes for
everyone but for me
i'm a producer too so writing in a group
is wonderful because if i can
bounce ideas off of someone not just in
a way of like hey i'm thinking of this
and then go write it hey i'm thinking of
this that can affect what they're
writing
and vice versa it's so much better
because my brain
because i've it's just what it is i'm
producer it will always go to a place
that has nothing to do with the script
like it will always it'll always creep
in somewhere but bouncing ideas off of
someone kind of vibing it out
that keep is that that keeps that at bay
enough where i could not think about a
budget for a moment or i could not think
about
this is too many locations you know
whatever it is i can silence that
productivity part of me and just like
feel free to write if i have someone in
the room
or if i have someone i can bounce off of
and for me and i know that can
be achieved on your own but for me so
far it's been the best when i get to
writing a group
you